let's make a damn good Korean spicy
chicken rice bowl I'm going to start by
getting our chicken going let it cook
while we make our sauce you'll need some
minced garlic Korean chili powder Korean
beef Brion chicken bouillon sweetener I
use monk fruit sweetener soy sauce Plum
syrup this is the one I use but you can
also use honey Marin oyster sauce give
it a good mix come back to our chicken
here beautifully cooked now we're gonna
pour our sauce all over it mix it all up
and we're going to continue cooking this
until the sauce reduces you'll know when
it's ready when you mix it up and it
starts to leave the streets on the
bottom of the pan couple different ways
I like to eat it of course over a fresh
bowl of steamed white rice topped with
toasted sesame seeds and some red butter
lettuce I love to mix it all up so that
the sauce is in every single bite
coating each grain of rice I also like
to eat it as a lettuce wrap sometimes so
I just add in some rice over my lettuce
some chicken and sauce and there you
have it a little lettuce wrap but let's
go back to the Bowl cheers
ha ha